[موسيقى]
اكثر من اربعين فنانا من ثلاثه عشره دوله
عربيه صعدوا على المسرح في ليله واحده
تكريما للفنان السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل
قبل اكثر من 22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن
من عطائه الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
عشاقه في السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي
كثيره في الفن السعودي
احد الاعمده المهمه في الفن السعودي اذا
جينا نؤرخ للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني فنؤرح
بالعين طلال مداح
ليله تمر
عط
ريق
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايه هيئه
الترفيه السعوديه بحضور الالاف من
الجماهير التي ما زالت تردد اغنيات الراحل
حتى يومنا هذا ومن مختلف الاعمار
سلمت عليه قلت لها ترجي من الشيخ فطاربي
واتحادي فكان يحسبني ولد عبد المحسن الشيخ
الداعم الاتحاد طلعنا غلبان وقال يضحك
وحضني اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه بالعود بهذا
العود اللي احتفظت ابوه 22 سنه وهو
الاستاذ طلال
ما هذا اقول
وقدمت فيك
حنيني هذه الليله جاءت بعد مبادره رئيس
الهيئه السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ
الذي قدم قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم
السعوديه والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه
وهو ما قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا وعربيا انتم
ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
يا عمر
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكل يطلع من عندي ما حد يكلمني
يعني اكون من ثاني
[موسيقى]